Haugh: Hi, everybody.
I'm Justin Haugh.
Darke:
And I'm Greg Darke.
Haugh: So I hope you guys
had a good lunch,
and you're ready
for something cool.
So we're here today to talk
about App Engine Backends.
I'm a software engineer
on the App Engines Systems
Infrastructure team.
Darke: And I'm also
a software engineer,
but I work on
the Task Queue Infrastructure.
Haugh: So there's
a few links on this page,
if you guys are following along,
a link to the session
and you can go
to SpeakerMeter
to rate our performance.
Okay, so we're here today to
talk about App Engine Backends.
We'll start off with a little
bit of a brief description
of how we do things
on App Engine,
why we do,
what that means,
and then we'll talk
about backends
and what they're offering,
go through
"Hello world" examples,
some configuration, and then,
we'll have a brief demo.
We'll wrap up with
some best practices,
caveats,
and the future.
Okay, so I just want to talk
just for a second
about the App Engine way
of doing things.
If you go back to the original
blog post for App Engine,
the goal of App Engine
is to make it easy to get
started with a new web app
and then make it easy
to scale that app
when it reaches the point
where it's receiving
significant traffic
and has millions of users.
So App Engine is supposed--
the goal of App Engine
is to have--
to provide
a very high performance
web application infrastructure
for your applications.
And what that means is,
it should be very easy
to deploy new apps.
It scales
dynamically for you.
You have
a really high performance
scalable storage layer,
a rich set of APIs,
and the whole philosophy
behind App Engine
is about breaking
very large problems,
like serving thousands
of queries a second,
into very small pieces
and performing them in parallel,
being fault-tolerant,
horizontal scaling.
So this is the philosophy
behind how App Engine works,
and you guys are probably
very familiar with that.
But there's a few things
about this philosophy.
Not everything
is a web app.
Maybe you just want to run
a command on the server
and generate a report.
What if you want to just have
a single global counter
or set of global counters
that are tracking data and
aggregate for your application.
These things are a little
hard to do.
You might have to
shard your counter
and have relatively
complex operations
to try to compute a total.
The instances
are very lightweight.
They have relatively low memory,
limited amounts of CPU,
and they're anonymous.
They're not addressable,
so you can't guarantee
that you're going back
to the same instance
on a second request.
There's 30-second deadlines,
which I'm guessing you guys
are familiar with.
And, again,
they're anonymous.
So there's a lot of
restrictions
that App Engine puts in place
in order to guide you
to making a very highly scalable
application.
Break things into small pieces,
30-second requests,
a lot of small instances
that grow and shrink
in response to traffic.
Well, today, we're announcing
something called backends,
which changes how things work
on App Engine.
This is the full
public release,
as of this morning,
of App Engine Backends.
We posted on the blog
this morning,
and this talk will be about
how backends work
and what they do for you.
They're a powerful new way
to write programs on App Engine.
They let you do things
that were not possible before,
and they make App Engine
much more of a complete
general purpose
computing platform.
So what are backends?
Backends
are App Engine instances
with some unique features.
They can run
for long periods of time.
They're high performance.
They're configurable.
Each backend
is addressable.
They're persistent in memory
over long periods of time.
These are high-performance cloud
processes running on App Engine.
They're powerful building blocks
for application
and can be combined
to make really interesting
high performance
distributed applications.
They're very easy to use,
and they're very flexible.
So what are the features?
Well, an App Engine backend
can be configured
with anywhere from 128 megs
up to a gigabyte of RAM.
They can use up to
4.8 gigahertz of CPU.
There's no request deadlines
to backends.
They can run indefinitely.
They can be addressed
individually.
They can be configured
to be resident in memory
for long periods,
or dynamic in response
to traffic,
and they automatically restart
if they ever go down,
and they're very App Engine-y.
They're easy to configure.
You can deploy them
very quickly.
You get all the nice graphs,
and consoles, and charts
that you're used to having
with App Engine,
and there's dev appserver
support for backends.
So what does this mean?
App Engine, again,
it's now much more of
a general purpose
cloud computing platform.
It's suitable for
high-performance servers.
You can do large amounts
of in-memory caching,
self-driven programs that start
and just run continuously,
tiered architectures, and
heavyweight offline processing.
And at this point,
App Engine is really suitable
for a lot more
than just websites.
So what are use cases
for backends?
Anything memory intensive
is a good fit.
So if you have
a web search index
that you want to keep
in memory,
or really any type of
search index,
if you want to have
a giant social graph
that you keep in memory,
if you're running
a game server,
if you want to do
your own custom memcache
with your own hash function
and sharding,
if you want to do something
that uses a lot of CPU,
image manipulation,
audio/video encoding.
If you're doing some
scientific computing,
App Engine now could be a better
fit for that, or, of course,
mean generation could be
definitely a case.
So background processing,
if you have a data pipeline
that's taking data and
performing several transforms,
something that runs
continuously,
that's a good fit.
A web crawler, task execution.
You can now handle tasks.
You can direct tasks
at a backend,
and they can just run
without a deadline, basically.
It's actually 24 hours,
but that's a little bit
of an improvement.
Commands and scripts,
you can issue a command yourself
to a dynamic backend.
It starts up.
It can just run
until the script is done.
You can have
ad-hoc queries.
You can have backends
that generate load
for your application,
and if you were
at the last talk,
you know how important
that is for building
a scalable app
or report generation.
So let's see "Hello world."
Okay, this is an app.yaml.
Looks pretty simple,
pretty familiar.
So what we add here
is a backends.yaml file,
and we're going to create
one backend named "Hello,"
and we'll make it public,
so that we can access it,
and it's available at
hellobackends-io.appspot.com.
So you'll notice that we're
addressing this backend
by adding the backend name
as a prefix to the URL.
So traffic,
without this prefix,
is directed to backends-io
dynamic application version
with the prefix instruct
at the backend.
And you can add instances.
So here's 15 instances.
Each one has an address,
and you can reliably
contact each instance
by appending
the instance index to the URL.
Hello.py,
pretty simple, right?
And we have added
this new backends API
with methods like
get the backend name.
You can get the instance
index of the backend
that you're working with.
There's functions for
computing the URL of a backend
or other backends
and the host name.
So commands for working
with backends,
these are new, as of 1-5-0.
Fairly familiar
backends update,
works a lot like
appcfg update does currently.
You could figure
your backend.
You run appcfg update,
and now you have a backend
that's running
in Google's cloud.
List, start,
stop, delete;
we'll get into
more of what those do.
So here's an example
of what this looks like--
pretty similar to
what you guys are used to.
If you do a list,
this is what you'll get back.
You're getting back the backend
config that the server has,
and you'll notice
that the state is "start."
So with backends, you can
start and stop them yourself,
and you can decide whether
they're serving traffic or not.
And appcfgbackends.stop
will stop the server.
And you can see, if you
do a list, that it stopped.
And again, you can
start and stop them.
Okay, so let's dive
into some configuration.
What can you do here?
So the backends.yaml file,
it lists each backend.
You can define up to five.
The app.yaml is the same
as it is before,
except the version
is now optional,
because you may have just an app
that only has backends,
so you can just configure
it that way.
The handlers that you are
normally used to working with
are still defined
in app.yaml,
and they're shared
by the app in any backends
that you have defined.
The code is also shared,
and you update each one
individually.
So here's what a more
fleshed-out backends.yaml file
will look like,
and I'll go into some of
these settings in just a second.
But here's a crawler.
We defined a start script
where the crawler runs main.py,
when it starts up.
Here's a search backend.
It's configured as a B8,
which has high memory in CPU,
five instances of this
and a worker.
Here, we've made
this worker dynamic,
so that it doesn't
always stay at memory.
It only comes up
in response to traffic
or a command that the worker
has to execute.
So you can see how we've added
a number of different
server processes,
each of which can be configured
with multiple instances
to your applications.
So now we essentially have
almost four different things
going on in this application:
the normal application version,
and each of these
three backends.
So things you can add
in backends.yaml,
the name is using commands
to identify the backend.
It's using URLs.
You can target a backend
using the--
with a task or with a cron job
by adding the target parameter
in syntax or the names
used there.
The name is global,
and it's shared
across the version space,
namespace
for your application,
and backends currently
are not versioned,
and it's using
in the backends API.
So instances--control
the number of instances
for your backend.
There are two ways that
the instances account works.
If you have a resident backend,
which is the default,
you always will have
exactly that many instances,
and when you
start the backend,
all of them come up
at the same time.
With a dynamic backend,
as I mentioned before,
the instances do not
come up immediately.
They wait until traffic arrives
and are brought up
and taken down,
as you're used to,
with a normal application
version on App Engine.
And in the instances
used in URL, like so,
like I showed before,
you can only have 20 instances
currently per backend.
The class specifies
the performance
and price characteristics
of the backend,
so we're going out today
with four classes:
B1, B2, B4, and B8,
and you can see the limits,
the memory and CPU limits,
and the prices.
And so
the price includes
the memory in the CPU
used by the instance,
and they're priced
by the hour,
or by the minute,
actually,
so we're tracking exactly the
uptime of each backend instance,
and you're billed according
to this hourly rate,
just according to how much
your backends are up.
There's an additional
15-minute charge
associated with starting up
a backend instance.
So once one is up,
you should try to keep it up.
We don't want
people creating
and bringing down backend
instances very rapidly.
And you can adjust the class,
over time,
if you want more memory
or CPU.
The start directive
configures a script
to handle
the /_ah/start request,
which is a special request
that App Engine will send
each backend instance
to start it up,
and the start directive
allows you to configure
a separate handler for this,
for each backend.
This is only in Python
right now.
We're working on something
similar in Java,
but there's two uses
for the start request
to initialize state
for a backends coming up,
that's going to then
process user requests
or to just take
that start request
and just continue to run,
like, if you're a web crawler,
or if you're doing a load test
or something like that.
And during the startup period,
other requests will wait
until the start finishes,
at which point
App Engine considers the backend
to have become initialized
and ready to serve traffic,
and success is basically
a 200-response code.
We also consider
a 404 a success.
A failed start causes
the instance to be restarted.
So if you're working
with backends,
and you're having trouble
seeing them come up,
go check the logs.
It's usually because that
the start request is filled.
So options, these are
a set of boolean flags
that configure
how backend works.
So public allows it to accept
external HTTP requests.
By default,
they're private,
and that means
that they accept requests
from either an admin
of the application
or from another instance
or the task queue
or cron,
something internal
to App Engine.
Dynamic, so this switches the
mode from resident to dynamic,
which causes the backends
to only come up
if they are
receiving traffic,
and there is
some scalability here,
up to the 20-instance limit
that I mentioned before.
So App Engine will only create
instances up to that 20,
according to traffic,
and they're shut down
when they're idle.
So dynamic is really a way
to give App Engine
more automatic control
of your backend instances,
which can save you money,
because they'll be turned down
kind of immediately,
relatively immediately
after they become idle.
Fail-fast is another option,
which disables the pending queue
for your backend instance,
which is useful
for working with clients
that are more sophisticated,
that want a very quick response
to just know whether
a request can be handled,
or should it be retried
or potentially tried later.
Okay, let's see a demo.
Greg is here, and will be
showing you some backends.
Darke: Okay, so I think
I will first start off
with a generic
counting service.
And so currently
people use memcache
to get this particular feature,
but the problem
with Memcache is that you don't
know how long the data
is actually going to last for,
as it's quite transient.
So with backends,
you get full control of this,
and you're able to have
your own hashing algorithm,
so you can shard it across
any backend you want.
You can control how long
the data is there for
and how much
you want to store.
And in this particular example,
this is actually
going to use Datastore
to do this
persistently.
So if you want to click
on the link down the bottom,
it'll show you an example
of this page.
And as you can see, it says,
"Welcome, visitor 2,"
because this is
the second person
who's visited the page.
So what I'll do is I'll
quickly go over the frontend
that I just demoed to you.
As you can see,
we use the new backends API
to use the get URL call
to get the URL
for the counter's backend.
We then use that URL and
the form and coding mechanism
to send the payload
with the name of the visitor,
delta=1, and we send
that to the backend,
and then the content that we
get back from that backend,
we just display
straight to the user.
So while I'm doing this,
I'll just start off a load test,
and I'm currently doing that
with a backend.
This is a resident backend.
It has ten instances.
I want to just
start that now,
and I'll actually
go over that code.
So this particular example,
we use the same method,
the get URL, to get where we're
going to send the request to,
and we have
ten different counters.
And as you see,
this is something
that you don't normally see
in App Engine.
You have a while true loop,
and that's it.
So we pick a random
counter.
We send that request
through with urlfetch,
and then we just
ignore the result
and go back through
on the loop.
So now on to the actual
other backend,
the counter backend.
So we have a fairly
simple model here.
There's only a single
value stored,
and that is value,
and that's written to Datastore.
We also have
this dirty flag,
and I'll get into that
a bit more later,
but that's not written
to Datastore.
So with the counting store,
it's quite simple.
We get the name in
from the request,
and we check if the model
exists in our cache,
and if not,
we load it from Datastore.
Once we've loaded it,
we then return it
back to the user,
if they did
a get request.
If it was an increase request,
what we do is we increase it
by the amount,
and we set the dirty flag
to be true.
You'll notice
the shutdown flag here.
What this is there for
is that your application may get
a shutdown request at any time,
and so we set
the shutdown flag
just after we've written
everything to disk.
I'll get to that
in a second.
This is the shutdown that I was
actually talking about.
So what we do is in the event
of this backend being shut down,
we write everything
to disk.
We set the shutdown flag
to true,
and then that will ensure
that everything is persisted
to disk correctly.
The way how we actually
set this shutdown hook
is in the start-off handler,
which is the first request
that goes to this instance.
We use the set shutdown hook
command.
So I'll go back to
the example load test
that I started out before.
You have a look
at the instances console.
You'll see that this particular
instance has been doing
about 120 requests per second.
It's quite good.
So we'll stop the load test,
and we'll have a look
at Datastore.
So if I do a query
on Datastore,
you'll see that it's empty,
so that there's actually
nothing in Datastore.
But if I go back
to the instances console
and press the shutdown button,
you'll see that a shutdown
request has been sent.
If we go back to the Datastore
viewer and run this query,
you'll see that all the counters
have actually been updated.
This is just a simple example
of doing a counter.
This particular example could
easily be moved to memcache,
but there are many more
advanced things
that you can actually do,
and the code for this example
is up on
backends-io.appspot.com.
and I'll pass it
back to Justin
for more information
about backends.
Haugh: All right,
thanks, Greg.
So let's talk about
using backends
and some best practices.
So we'll cover using resident
backends versus dynamic.
We'll cover scaling,
startup and shutdown,
how logging works with backends
during long-running requests,
a little bit more
about fail-fast,
some ideas about message passing
between frontends and backends
and instances,
how task queues work,
and handlers, so--
a lot to get through.
Okay, resident backends.
So a resident backend,
as I mentioned before,
they are always on,
so they are always up,
once you start the backend.
Automatically
will be restarted,
if anything happens
to cause a shutdown,
so if you go to that instances
console that Greg showed,
and hit shutdown,
they'll come right back up.
If there's an App Engine
maintenance,
and we're potentially moving
from one data center to another,
they'll be immediately brought
up in the new data center.
If there's any other issues
that may occur,
they come right back.
Resident instances also
just can run forever,
so you can take the start
request and just run,
and because they're restarted,
you can reliably know
that this backend
will be taking start
and just kind of
running continuously.
So these are really great for,
like, background,
continuous background
processing applications,
explicit start and stop,
like I mentioned before,
so they're going to stay up
and resident in memory
until you stop them
yourself.
So uses for this, again,
continuous execution.
Pull queues
is a great example,
where you have a backend
that comes up,
and it chooses to pull requests
from a pull queue
and passes a process task
in batch
that can be a lot more efficient
that using push queues.
These are great for large
addressable amounts of memory.
So let's say you have,
I don't know,
let's say you have a lot of data
in the Datastore.
You want to load it all up
in the memory
and then access it
at memory speed,
so like, sub millisecond
or on the order of, you know,
just very, very quickly perform
any sort of computation
you want over that data.
You can have
that in a backend,
and you can split it up
across backends,
so that you can address, like,
say, you could shard users
so that users are split
across the backends,
and you can know,
hash the user name
and go contact the backend
that has that user's data,
and it could be flushed
at shutdown time
or periodically,
like Greg showed,
or you can write your own
custom Memcache using backends.
So the pattern here
is that at start time,
load up some state,
and then handle request,
or just do start
and run continuously.
So dynamic backends
are similar
to existing instances
on App Engine,
except that you configure
the amount of memory in CPU
they have access to,
and there's a limit
of 20 of them.
So these only come up
when they're sent a request.
At that point, App Engine will
kind of hold the user's request
and issue the start
to bring up the backend;
and once the backend is up,
it will handle the user request.
So with these,
you really want to minimize
the amount of time,
amount of state you're
initializing at startup
or perform some kind of
routing on your own
or some sort of, like,
warm-up requests on your own
to get the dynamic instances up
before you flip traffic over,
if you want to do
a lot of state initialization.
So here, you pay
for what you use.
You do this with resident,
as well,
but with dynamic backends,
they'll be turned down,
if there's not traffic
for a few minutes,
and there's no management
of start and stop,
so you can configure
a backend to be dynamic
and really not have to worry
about doing too much management
with that backend.
The counter server
that Greg mentioned
would function as
a dynamic backend as well,
because it was integrated
with your application.
If it was getting traffic,
it would be in memory.
It would be working.
As traffic fell off,
it would be shut down.
It'd flush its state, and
you wouldn't be paying for it.
So the pattern here,
load up a little bit of state,
handle requests,
and then write out state,
either intermediately
or during shutdown.
So, scaling.
I just gave a talk
on scaling.
backends don't scale the same
way that normal applications.
This is due on App Engine.
They're designed to work
either online or offline,
but they really, really shine
when it comes to offline work,
because you're controlling
the number of instances.
You're controlling
the amount of throughput
that your offline processing
is handling.
If you hit limits,
if you're maxing out the memory
and CPU of your backends,
you're just going to have a--
your processing is going to
slow down a little bit,
but nothing that bad happens.
And if you want to resize,
you can pause
the offline execution,
resize it
and bring it right back up.
No big deal.
When you integrate a backend
into an online web flow,
you're usually not in control
of the traffic
that's coming at that backend,
unless you are rerouting traffic
between different versions
of your application
or different backends.
If you hit limits
in a web flow,
if you scale up to
all 20 backends,
and they're running out of,
kind of, CPU,
they're maxing out their CPU,
it could be a problem
for your application.
So we urge caution when
you're introducing backends
into an online flow.
We'd like for you
to carefully consider
and monitor the resource usage
and probably overprovision,
or if you're using
dynamic backends,
just, again, be careful
about the resource usage,
because there is
that 20-instance limit.
App Engine will scale you up
to that 20,
but there is that fixed limit
currently.
So look at the instances
console.
We're also providing
a new runtime API,
which exposes the CPU and
memory usage of each instance.
And using this,
you can dynamically see
how your instances
are performing.
The strategies
for dealing with situations
where you're kind of hitting
limits of your backends,
the default is to just take
a little bit of downtime.
You do an update,
add some more instances.
There's a brief window,
when you're doing an update,
where the old instances
of your backend are taken down,
and then new ones
are brought up.
So if you minimize
the shutdown time,
and you minimize
that start time,
that can be
a very short window,
and you won't really see
a whole lot of downtime.
A better option probably would
be to do some routing yourself,
where you have two backends,
A and B, or 1 and 2.
Bring up the second one,
flip the traffic over,
take down the first one.
And this is useful for doing
canaries of new code
or doing a little bit
of staging.
The best option is probably,
again, to use options dynamic
where App Engine will scale you
up to those 20 instances.
You could do custom routing
logic yourself,
where you have
more instances configured
than you're actually using,
typically,
and proxy requests through some
of your own application logic.
If you don't target a request
at a backend instance,
it won't actually come up;
so you could choose
to only load balance
across some fraction
of the configured instances
like five or ten out of 20
and kind of
just on the fly,
using some
configuration command,
or an admin request
to change that.
Okay, so
let's move on to startup.
I mentioned before
that this AH start request
is a special request
that App Engine will send
to bring up
your backend instances.
This is sent
for resident backends
as soon as you
hit the start,
start the backend.
With a dynamic backend,
again,
it only arrives
when a user request arrives,
and it allows you
to then run indefinitely.
And I think I've pretty much
covered this, then.
So shutdown,
there's two types of shutdown,
polite and a hard shutdown.
So with polite shutdown,
we give your backend instance
30 seconds of notice
before it's terminated.
This allows you to do
some checkpointing of state.
And so some examples of when
polite shutdown occurs
are when machines
undergo maintenance,
when App Engine undergoes
maintenance.
If there's a scheduling change,
and we have to move your backend
instance to a different machine,
those are all examples
of polite shutdown.
So most of the time,
we expect to be able to provide
polite shutdown notice
for your backend instances.
Hard shutdown is when we
don't have that opportunity.
When a machine dies,
this can happen.
If there's some sort of
hardware failure,
if you've exceeded
your memory limits,
if there's some problems with
the network to a data center,
that can be a case
where we have a hard shutdown.
So when this occurs,
there's not a lot of time.
Really, there's no time
to write out any state.
So a best practice then
is to don't-- use the backend
as a cache of data
that's persistent
or be okay with
a little bit of loss.
And you really need to figure
out how to handle shutdowns.
So the runtime API
is what we've provided.
There's two methods
of handling shutdown.
The first method is to pull
the is shutting down method.
This will flip to True,
when you are being shut down,
and you'll have
30 seconds of notice
to do whatever you'd like.
So in this example,
we have backend that's looping.
It's doing work
for ten seconds each time.
Then it will check
the shutting down,
and if so, it'll checkpoint
and break out of the loop.
The other way
is the shutdown callback,
that Greg mentioned.
So you define the callback,
the checkpoint callback,
and just shutdown hook
when you start up,
and you can just
work continuously.
So this is a little bit
easier.
Okay, so the way logging
works with backends--
so these requests
can take a long time.
Normally, logs are only written
out to the admin console
at the end of a request.
But with backends,
we automatically flush logs,
and there's this
log service API
that we've introduced
that has constants.
You continue to decide
how often the auto flush works;
every so many bytes
of log messages,
every so many log lines
or seconds,
and you can manually flush
whenever you'd like.
Okay, so fail-fast.
This is for sophisticated
clients
that want to know immediately
when a request can't be handled,
and they have some sort of
alternative strategy.
They have their own ability
to have a queue of requests,
things that they need done,
external queuing systems,
an example of this,
they want to perform
their own retries,
or they have some sort of
fallback behavior.
So if you configure
your backend with options,
fail-fast, all the requests
to that backend
will get fail-fast
behavior.
On the client side,
you can set this
with a new header called
X-AppEngine-FailFast,
and that causes
that particular request
to have fail-fast behavior;
so client or server side.
Okay, message passing.
With backends,
you can have requests
that are running
for long periods of time.
So it's not always possible
to send a backend to request.
If it's a single-threaded
instance,
you can't really send it
another request
until the first one
is finished;
and if it's running
for a long time,
that can be a little
problematic.
So urlfetch, you know,
of course,
is kind of the typical way
you'd exchange information
between instances.
They could just
fetch each other.
But when you have this
long-running request,
you probably
want to use something
like memcache or datastore,
where you have a reader
and a writer.
So the writer
is writing entities.
They're probably annotated
with the backend instance name
or instance ID,
and the backend is then reading
and periodically pulling
to see if there's a message
or if there's something
for it to do.
You can also use
task queues for this.
It's really convenient.
If you want to
send something out,
send a message to backend,
you just insert.
You just add the target,
and that task will be
directed at a backend,
or if you use pull queues,
each backend
could have its own queue
that's just periodically
pulling tasks from.
And if someone wants
to send it a message,
you can just put something
in the pull queue.
And so that brings us
to task queues.
So I think I've pretty
much covered this.
There's the target directive
and queues.yaml.
There's the target parameter
to taskqueue.add.
That's how you target
a backend.
And with pull queues,
you can decide how many tasks
you want to lease.
You lease them
for a brief period
and then complete them.
There's a talk coming up
right after this called,
"Putting Task Queues to Work,"
which will go into
a lot more detail
about how pull queues work
and the differences between
push and pull queues,
when you might want to use
the different options.
So the last best practice
I'll talk about
is code and handlers.
So with this release,
all the handlers
for your application in Python
are specified in app.yaml.
For Java, they're expressed
in webxml, the servlets.
We don't currently have
a mechanism for you
to specify a different set
of handlers for backends,
so if you have a set of URLs
that you only want to express
or expose in a backend,
we advise you to mark them
with login admin.
If other instances of your
application access those URLs,
they'll be able to do this
seamlessly
without any additional
configuration,
but they'll be protected from
open requests on the web.
Another strategy would be
to have two directories:
an app directory
and then a directory
where you have
your backends.
The app.yaml in the main
app pretty much stays the same,
but then in the backends
directory,
the app.yaml will have the
handlers for just the backends,
and you don't have to go
through this work
of adding login admin,
because you don't have to
worry about those handlers
being exposed
in the main application.
Or you could have
a directory for each backend,
and you kind of
get the idea there.
If you're downloading
some third party backend
that somebody else has written,
you want to integrate it
into your application.
You can just have
a directory for that.
In that app.yaml,
just don't have the version,
don't have a version
of your application.
The handlers there will be
the handlers for the backend,
and when you do an update,
it will only update
that backend.
And if a backend is missing
in a backends.yaml,
it's not deleted.
It's sort of additive.
When you do an update,
it will only update the backends
listed in backends.yaml.
Okay, so we've heard a lot
about backends,
a lot of great things,
but some caveats.
Okay, so currently,
you can only configure
five backends
for your application.
You can have
up to ten gigabytes total
across all the different
backends,
adding up all the instances
of each backend.
A backend can have 20 instances,
and here's some combinations
of how you can arrive
at ten gigabytes.
You can either have ten B8's,
each of which is a gig,
20 B4's, which are
half a gig each,
and you can get the idea.
So all the normal API deadlines
still apply.
So urlfetch deadlines
The datastore has a 30-second
deadline for requests.
Size limits apply,
so HTTP requests to a backend,
you can have
32 megabyte requests.
The total size of all requests
to your backends,
your backend instance
is also limited.
So if you're using
very large requests,
you need to sort of serialize
them a little bit.
Urlfetch, memcache,
blobstore, mail, tasks.
So all of these normal limits
are still in place.
What we've done is just swapped
out the instance
that's performing
these API calls.
Also there's not
an uptime guarantee
for backends right now.
This is a best effort service.
You should expect shutdown.
You should expect polite
shutdown most of the time.
You should write
your application
the way that tolerates
hard shutdown,
and there's various causes,
like I've mentioned:
software bugs, hardware
failures, emergencies.
I would strongly recommend
you guys check out the talk
called "Life in App
Engine Production,"
which is tomorrow.
Michael Handler and Alan Green
are giving this talk.
It's a great talk.
Definitely check it out.
There's a lot of interesting
stuff going on in production.
So the future.
There's a lot of things
that we are releasing today
with backends, but there's
a lot more we can do.
Better scaling.
So you've seen how backends
can scale up to 20 instances.
We're looking into ways
of introducing auto scaling,
the same auto scaling behavior
we have for frontend versions,
which is another term
we sometimes use
when we're referring to
the main app version,
introducing that for backends,
as well.
We're considering
a scaling API
to give you
a little more control,
where you can dynamically
increase the number
of instances of your backend
at any time.
Better updates, so that you
don't have a period of downtime
when you're performing updates,
so each instance is kind of
updated in sequence.
Or you have online updates,
where if you just want to
change the number of instances,
you don't have to take down
the existing ones.
You can just change that number,
and the new ones will come up.
We're looking to
better concurrency;
so background threads in Java,
Python concurrency,
so that a single Python
backend instance
can essentially handle more
than one request at a time.
We're looking into ways
of doing that.
And better configuration,
which solve some of the problems
around having handlers
be the same for both backends
and the application version.
And also versioning for backends
is on our radar.
Better uptime.
Backend uptime is pretty good,
but minimizing restarts
and keeping them up
as long as possible
is something we're going
to continue to work on,
and we'll have some statistics,
over time,
to share with you about that.
There'll be API integrations,
more of them.
I'd recommend you guys
check out the MapReduce talk.
There'll be ways
to configure backends
to be MapReduce workers,
or to send mail out of backend,
or have a backend share,
a channel that a frontend
instance created.
Also looking at more power,
so new instance classes,
over time, longer deadlines,
larger API calls.
These are things that the
serving infrastructure team
is always thinking about.
And potentially streamed
responses and sockets.
So just to recap, I think
you can say that backends
really sort of redefine
what App Engine is.
It's not just for
30-second requests.
lightweight web serving.
It's really for
heavyweight processing,
offline processing,
large in memory indexes.
We're giving you a lot of memory
and CPU to work with.
backends are a building block
that you guys can use
to build a lot of
really cool stuff.
And, lastly, they're both
very easy to configure.
They have all the production
support, deployment,
and ease of use that you're
used to with App Engine,
and they're managed
by our Google production,
a team of crack
production engineers,
who are amazing
at solving problems
that you guys don't even
have to know about.
And that's it.
So thank you for coming,
and if you guys
have any questions,
please come up to the mics,
and we'll have some time
for questions.
[applause]
man: Hi, could you share
some best practices
for coping with
hard shutdowns?
Haugh: So the best practice
is to expect hard shutdown,
and use the memory
of your backend
as primarily a cache.
If you are worried about--
if you're tolerant of small
amounts of data loss,
or if the state is being
regenerated from the Datastore
or can be regenerated
from the Datastore,
that's really the ideal.
That's what I'd say there.
Darke: And I'd also suggest
you look at
the actual example code that is
for that counters demo.
That example also uses
the task queue
to flush the state
back out to datastore
about every two seconds,
and you can make it go faster,
if you want to.
man: You said
extended API deadlines.
Are you talking about
urlfetch as one example?
Haugh: Yeah,
that's one example.
man:
Soon.
Haugh:
Mmm-hmm.
man: What are some examples
of real world apps
that are being written
with backends
either at Google
or with partners?
Haugh: Oh, that have been
written right now?
I don't think I can really
mention anything at the moment
that's using backends.
We have plans to use backends
for some App Engine services
in the future, but they're
nothing ready to announce.
All right.
All right, well,
thank you, everyone,
and enjoy using
App Engine Backends.
[applause]